yeah welcome to this video let's play a
French defense playing on zari is the
sum the Chinese flag yeah very little
sometimes those details um can can be
deceiving but this is really China okay
I'm playing the screen takes d5 line
recently analyzed in this book that I
mentioned already quite a couple of
times but I got and until this about him
the French defense playing the French it
is caught and I must admit that I had a
bet I've looked through the book and and
liked it but I didn't really study
anything in big detail which you can see
here because I don't know how this is
played long castles yeah I knew that
this line exists but not really how to
how to play this looks own quite quite
normal tho kappa white is very well
developed
it didn't waste any time and test all
pieces in play interesting I know that
oh I knew that this line exists with
bishop Queenie too but as mentioned i
don't i don't know any details hmm
hmm while Kim it looks very dangerous
Jim
yeah you know I probably have to Castle
I mean how do i play this without
castling yeah yeah this is some probably
threatening night takes d5 now okay 95 I
guess no wow this 97 yeah my deaf 7 this
is some this is some threat problem
yeah how do I defend that I can't buy
him can play age six if I want hmm
Brooke t8 it's not really defending
against the the sacrifice
yeah this 97 moves is really a problem
okay maybe just mechanically stop him
from from taking here just blocking the
diagonal if he takes I take with the
pawn why not Tigs Bishop takes 97 I can
take on d4 with the Queen but I lose the
rock on a fade wow how this was a
nonsense okay maybe Bishop takes Bishop
takes 97 I can play a 3d 6 yeah night
xf8 Bishop takes d4 gather this as
possible okay um yeah Bishop takes
Bishop takes rook takes d5 I thought
queen before might be okay at least I'm
not I'm not mated yeah you can take on
f6 then play g3 just claiming a
positional edge and with good reason
probably night f8 Bishop g4 check looks
okay to me yeah now just g3 hmm
okay let's try for sim card to play him
hmm we can play a 5 I have to check okay
and five is not the end of the world
okay yeah if you take ciego queen f tune
activating he's got the slight weakness
on a form of course why this better oops
oops yeah white is better and this is I
didn't see it all but I can give the
check here check
and this is a this is a problem okay do
I have something better probably not him
but at least I'm not made which is
completely lack just just luck so let's
see yeah okay no no i don't i didn't
want to play that one I wanted to play h
5 which is bad and then I wanted to play
g6 not age 6 okay yeah yeah well stupid
is dead well okay
the a g6 is just the more useful move in
comparison
yeah get Slocum behind through before
the spells trouble
hmm Jim my king is cut off which is a
bit of a problem
well still
he's got a double porn so it's not clear
that this exchange is actually winning I
don't think so at all and oh that's
surprising really surprising should be a
very easy game now for me yeah well you
can draw the belly with h4 you can draw
kingi ford edge for the right cannot win
of course that's over
I am drawn yeah I'm very very lucky safe
but okay he simply cannot exchange rooks
this is quite quite obvious that Addison
is it wrong the computer says white it's
winning this is very surprising for me
at least p 6 winning what and now my
opponent is display moves I really
should should someone switch that off
because it just irritates I played g5
the contest Kingda four wins here
yeah of this Leah this is winning of
course he simply must avoid must avoid
to this is winning he's these two pawns
are too far away yeah white wins in
there and the king and porn endgame I'm
sorry the letters screwed up because
he's constantly moving some stuff here's
already a win for white very easily even
I'm just I'm just promoting yeah okay
but it was maybe still the best the best
chance i need to somehow um switch that
off and it's irritating i'm not sure
what he's doing here because it's very
obvious that the Dwight wins okay well
thanks for watching